Hello there, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're The Slow Mo Guys.
Dan, one of my favorite treats
back when I lived in the UK
was a lovely pack of Maltesers.
Yeah, never used to be able
to get them in America,
but they've recently launched in the U.S.,
so they're all over the gaff now.
So we thought, being from England,
why not give them our
own Slow Mo Guys launch?
Yeah, at 800 feet per second
with this massive air cannon.
Hello, America.
I'm here!
And we're gonna film it
at ridiculous frame rates
on the Phantom V2511.
Shall we start with a melon?
Lets, I've got one
right here oddly enough.
Let's do it.
All right, so how does
this device work then?
Kinda complicated, but we got
high pressure nitrogen here,
fed through a tube all the way into here,
which is like a regulator valve.
Now this, when it makes a sound,
That's a good sound.
That's filling up the
chamber with pressure, okay?
Up to 150 PSI, which is regulated by that.
When it stops making noise,
that means it's full.
All right.
Okay, so now we got our gas in here,
and this is like our valve to release it,
so it's armed and then you press fire,
and that's what releases the gas.
Solenoid?
Uh, it's called, yes, solenoid valve.
That's right, well done.
Yes!
Venturi here, increases the pressure
going into the chamber,
and this here is our chamber
where we load the Malteser in.
Oh, okay.
So that's where we're going,
and if it fits, it sits.
So you put it in there,
screw it up.
Yep.
And then we've got our tube here,
gets fired along here with the pressure,
and our object that's gonna be
imminently destroyed sits here.
That's the goodbye zone.
Yeah, this isn't going to be here for
when we're shooting stuff,
but this is a tester to
find out how far stuff goes.
What's our highest Malteser so far?
Fluke one, 900 feet per second,
which is faster than a .45 caliber round
that comes out of the muzzle of a pistol.
Phew.
So, it's pretty intense.
We might as well be using a firearm.
Might as well just be
sitting there with a pistol.
Yeah.
And then we got a backboard
over there to catch the mess.
Yes, absolutely.
Malteser, as you can see.
Ready to get loaded
in, just pops in there.
Screw this up, that's our chamber.
Cool, okay, so I'm gonna gas the tube.
Arming.
Three, two, one.
Oh!
Goodness me!
I think we need to clean our glass.
Oh, that's the air?
Oh!
What's that, is that just
all the air being released?
It comes with a lot of air.
Whoa!
I need to adjust the exposure,
there's a lot of air and
spray that's so bright.
Yeah.
All right, I think we
should do that again.
So we've seen what
happens with one Malteser,
but what happens if we do two Maltesers?
Got two here,
let's see if we can bung
both of them in there.
One, two.
Ready for gas.
Good sound, innit?
So meaty.
Three, two, one!
Whoa!
Bloody hell, that was a different spray.
You got hit over there?
I got watermelon brains on me.
Here's our unsuspecting
watermelon just chilling out.
That was a really good escalation.
Yeah.
Oh, wait!
One after the other!
What do you think determines that gap?
I have no idea.
I mean, Maltesers aren't perfectly round
so maybe that's just,
like, the different shapes
cause them to come through
at different times.
That's opened it up like
an absolute beaut there.
Definite evisceration.
Look at the chunks!
How does something as light as a Malteser,
or sorry, two Maltesers,
do that to a watermelon?
You'd need to use a
sledgehammer to get that affect
as a human, wouldn't you?
Yeah.
Unbelievable.
Oh, is that the furthest chunk?
That's the furthest chunk I've seen.
That must be 30 meters,
or something like that.
Go see if our Maltesers will
go through a soda pop can.
Ready?
Yep.
Three, two, one.
Whoa!
The second one is so funny to me.
Yeah, it's always, like, way too late
to do anything about it.
It was like the can was a human
and got punched in the gut,
the way it buckled down, like oh!
Yeah it did.
I'm controlling the laptop
today because we're indoors.
I'm gonna reduce the resolution
on this one to 512 by 320,
not remotely HD, or even SD.
I'm gonna shoot 118,000 frames a second,
just to get that crushing
impact of the Malteser
around here.
Arming.
All right, three, two, one.
Oh!
I like how it seems to
make you jump every time.
You're the one doing
it and you're like, oh!
Yeah, oh come on!
This is 120.
Whoa!
Did you see the tear on
the can go around there?
Yeah!
That must have been so quick.
I almost want to see that frame by frame.
Yeah.
Oh, wow!
Oh!
That's amazing.
God.
Look at that flowering effect.
That's so cool.
The way it just sort of popped it.
It flattens itself
so a lot of the energy
is absorbed by itself,
but it still has enough force.
Is that Malteser there?
Just bits of Malteser crushed?
Yeah.
So I was lookin', and I was
wondering if I could find
the piece of can that the Malteser hit.
I wondered if it just,
like, shattered the can?
I would've thought it would
just split it and go through.
Apparently not,
because I found the exact
piece that the Malteser hit.
It's even concaved like a
sphere from the Malteser.
Look it.
Yeah.
Perfectly hit.
So we're going for something
a bit more substantial this time.
Ping pong bat here.
Do you think it'll go through?
I think it will go through.
I have faith.
You don't think it'll go through?
No, 'cause plywood is
always layered isn't it?
It's layered to be strong.
It'll go through.
It'll go through?
Yeah.
All right.
Three, two, one.
Oh!
What?
Did it go through or did it go through?
It went straight through
like it was nothin'.
I owe you 10 bucks.
You do.
Bugger me!
It couldn't be cleaner,
it's like a bullet hole.
Geez.
Look at the exit there.
That is nasty exit wound.
A perfect Malteser size though.
I was a bit worried because I thought,
is it going to ping back and hit me?
See you later!
Geez!
Did you see the ripple of the rubber there
and the wood just flying out the back?
Being hit by a cannon.
Yeah, we've been shootin' a
lot of stuff that's, like,
I knew would go, like a melon or a drink.
That surprised me.
I don't know why it surprised
me considering the speeds.
The air from the cannon is going like.
Yeah.
Got the fast camera, got a fast Malteser,
perfect for smashing some glass.
How do you feel about vases?
Yeah, I've got a few of them at home.
Yeah?
Yeah, I like 'em.
Why do you hate this one so much?
It's rank isn't it?
Three, two, one.
We've yet to beat these Maltesers.
Ah, what can't they destroy?
This glass is thick.
Goodness me.
Now that was weird.
It went and hit and it
looked like it stopped,
and then the Malteser
sort of went into itself,
and then it went in more.
Yeah, it was like it, the vase,
it absorbed all the Malteser's power
and just shattered.
I want to see that
frame by frame, hold on.
There's one frame in there
that looks astonishing.
Or maybe, there, that's the one.
Look at it!
The motion blow on that.
So, we've done a vase.
Right, so we've done a vase.
I thought we could do a vase
but filled with different colored paint.
I just, I feel like you're trying to make
the biggest mess possible.
Yeah.
Three, two, one.
Whoa!
That is a bigger mess
than I was expecting.
That is a monster.
Look at this tripod.
Oh no!
Whoa, straight through.
The second just doubles it up.
God.
It's amazing how much it went forwards.
Yeah.
That's just blowin' it completely away.
It's like a black hole
would go off on a planet.
Imagine if you hadn't covered the camera
with plexiglass.
So now we've made this giant mess,
let's revisit the ping pong bat,
and get a gnarly exit wound, shall we?
Yeah, see if we can see all
the wood flying out the back.
Bet you 10 bucks it goes through.
I'm not taking that bet.
I might put another Malteser in there,
just to see it come through the hole
that we've already made by the Malteser.
That's a good idea.
So it's like, exit wound, and then, hello.
Yeah!
I like that.
Three, two, one.
Whoa!
It just took the bat off.
Bloody hell!
It just removed the bat instead.
Oh, and it went through as well.
It went through too?
I wonder if just the left over air
from the blast.
Oh, it just destroyed it.
Straight through, it's dust.
The other one turned to dust as well.
Oh yeah!
The other one came through the hole,
but it was all, sort of, ripped up,
so it just became nothing also.
And then now the air's
blowing it off the handle.
Yeah.
But I think a lot of it is to do with,
on the other turn, it was nailed,
but also, a lot of the
paddle was behind the plank,
because it was on the other side
it had less strength in that direction.
So, we've fired through
quite a lot of stuff
with Maltesers right?
So far, we've found
that it seems to obliterate
on the first hit.
Yeah.
So I thought we could do a test
where we put 3 Maltesers in the chamber,
and have three pieces of glass,
and we see if the first one
will smash the first pane,
second one will smash the second pane,
and third on the third.
So we're gonna see if
it's like a one to one,
three for three sort of basis?
I'm wondering if we can
go bang, bang, bang,
because we know they
follow quite soon after.
But here's the thing
though, by the third one,
it's gonna be going through
the shards and debris
of the first two panes,
so I don't think this one will break.
You don't think it will,
that's your prediction?
No, I think this one will definitely,
that one, yeah, no.
Yeah.
Three, two, one.
Oh!
Wow!
Damn it!.
Gone through all three.
Now I wonder, if it will be as I hoped,
where each individual one
smashed it's own pane of glass?
That was safety glass.
I know.
You can hear the lovely
safety glass popping.
Okay, here's the first one.
Malteser one.
Through the first pane.
Oh, it's just nothin'
Oh come on, come on.
Yes!
Oh it's done it.
Malteser number two.
Where's the third one?
Is the third one gonna thread the needle?
Oh, here it comes.
Wait, if it shatters beforehand.
It did.
Oh, it shattered beforehand.
The third one's made it through though.
Is it gonna make it through there?
It comes bustin' through.
It's so fast that the tiny shards
of chocolatiness and glassiness
actually destroyed the third pane.
Now what we need to do
is load it up with 20,
and get 20 panes of glass.
How many can we get through?
Now we're gonna switch up
the camera and the angle
to get some much wider,
higher resolution shots
of the destruction, but
we've run out of Maltesers.
That's all right, we'll
just open another bucket.
Let's do it.
Three, two, one.
I like how all the air has
gone in through the hole,
and out through the lid.
So the Malteser went
in, smashed it all up,
air filled it, and the lid blew off.
Yeah.
Through the Malteser hole.
You know what I like about pineapples?
Go on.
Pretty much everything,
but I would prefer it
if this pineapple was over
there and a bit on the wall.
Luckily, we have the perfect
contraption for that.
Three, two, one.
Oh!
Have a look at this footage.
This is a perfect example
of why we needed to use the other camera.
Because this is the Malteser.
What?
You caught the frame of it.
The Malteser, apparently, is this long.
So our exposure time here,
is about a three thousandth of a second,
so in one three thousandth of a second,
it moved from there to there.
Goodness me.
It moved that streak.
So it's a good job we
got all the other shots
on the first camera.
This is a slow motion camera
that can't even see it.
One frame of Malteser.
So this is our pineapple.
Before,
after.
It just looks like someone has
taken a big bite out of it,
except it was a Malteser,
sort of, sized bite.
If horse took a bite out of it.
Three, two, one.
So, one thing I've noticed
while using the Phantom Flex
at, like, 1,600 fps, is that
the Malteser is fast as heck.
It's just like one streaky blur.
It's like a streak of, yeah.
So, now we're gonna film
it from a standstill
as it accelerates all the way
up to the end of the pipe,
and I think for nice
scale speed reference,
if you just drop a
Malteser at the same time,
so you can sort of see, that's gravity,
and that is how fast that's
moving in comparison.
Yeah, so I've got to trigger
it and drop at the same time.
Yeah.
I think by the time I've let go,
it will already be out the end.
Yeah, just don't trigger
it before you let go.
So I let go and trigger.
All right, cool.
I think I can manage that, yeah.
The thing is, I wonder if you could tell
the acceleration as well, like
if it's a small blur here,
and then a faster, bigger blur here?
Should be.
Malteser grabbed.
Right?
Three, two, one.
I hope I timed that right.
It looked like you did.
Yeah.
The Malteser has been released.
Releasing Malteser.
It looks like it's space, doesn't it?
It looks like I'm in space here,
like I've let something go in zero G.
Malteser inside hasn't started moving yet.
I reckon it'll be about
there before it does.
Whoa!
Wait, what?
I think I missed it.
Do it again, do it again.
God!
All right, you have to tell me,
because I completely missed it.
Okay, ready?
Yep.
Vroom!
Oh yeah!
So how far did it move
when it was dropping there?
A centimeter maybe?
Like from there, to there.
It moved like one length of itself.
So it moved one Malteser.
So in the amount of time it took for it
to get from the beginning
to the end of the barrel.
That is a very good speed comparison.
It took one Malteser.
Well Dan, I thought
that was a fantastic
amount of destruction.
Made a nice piece of art as well.
As we usually do.
Yeah.
Do you think a Malteser
has ever gone that fast?
Absolutely not.
There is no way a Malteser
has gone that fast before.
You'd have to, I don't know,
fire it into space or something.
Or just take packet of
Maltesers on a plane,
and technically that would
be faster wouldn't it?
Okay, fine, fine, I mean, maybe like,
relative to someone else three feet away,
one's never moved faster.
Okay, yeah, all right.
Thanks to Maltesers for
sponsoring this video.
Yeah, I always appreciate a company
that let's us advertise their products
by absolutely trashing them.
Always good, yeah.
Until there's none left, it's dust.
Feel free to follow us on Twitter,
subscribe to this channel.
We've got a second channel too,
and we will see you very soon
for the next video.
Yeah, give us a click.
Click, click, click.
Clicks and waves.